hi everyone it's Jerry I have another
chess composition to share with you this
one was published in 1924 and composed
by one of my favorites Frederick Lazar
it's white to move if you'd like to go
ahead pause the video spend some time
with this and see if you can find the
best continuation
okay a couple notes before I share the
solution
the current state both Rooks are Under
Fire
so attempting to on move one capture the
black Rook
is met with the capture the white rook
and the resulting position is a draw
the bishop
stops the a pawn
and the King stops all of the f-pawns
so the winning way is to land a check
forcing
and only reply King takes Pawn
and yet again we find ourselves in a
similar boat
Pawn takes Rook would now be met with
King takes Rook that's a draw
so another check is in order Rook G7
there goes Pawn number two same story
here chop met with chop another check
required there goes Pawn three
and for and five and six Pawns in a row
Must Fall throw all of it the white King
has merely been a spectator
until now on move 7 where it can finally
assist with this seventh and final check
the king is a reliable Defender
only after
the king moves on this move seven can we
safely take the rook and white is simply
winning
the plan from here is to guard this
square and push the pawn something like
this and of course white wins
now of all the composition compositions
I've shared by Mr Lazar this is one of
the lighter ones to be sure this is more
about Aesthetics this visual of the
white Rook beginning on G1 and making
use of all other G file squares giving
up all of the F pawns like this luring
the black king down to a point where the
white king can now assist in protecting
The Rook only at that point do we pick
up the Rook
what'd you think of this one did you get
it right
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it yeah
maybe found this one a little bit fun
that's all for now take care bye
foreign